le mauvais temps fait des victimes dix
morts en montagne et 90 communes du gard
déclarées sinistrées otage les rebelles
du tchad attendent une réaction
officielle de la france réponse du quai
d'orsay
cette affaire doit se traiter au plan
humanitaire le franc mauvaise fin de
semaine raymond barre à lyon
le gouvernement a la responsabilité les
moyens d'éviter la détérioration de
notre monnaie
les américains et les énergies nouvelles
à la pointe de la recherche le solaire
un reportage des doigts alors madame
mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir en moins
de 24 heures dix personnes donc dix
personnes au moins sont mortes dans les
alpes victimes d'avalanches dans la
vallée de chamonix ce matin trois
chalets ont été littéralement soufflé
par une énorme coulée de neige
quatre personnes ont été tuées et hier
dans le val d'aoste en italie huit
personnes qui se trouvaient dans leur
voiture ont été ensevelis sous d'énormes
masses de neige
deux seulement ont pu être dégagées
vivantes hier soir dans toutes les alpes
les risques restent permanent il a
beaucoup neigé ces derniers jours
d'énormes masses de neige peuvent
déferler vers les vallées à n'importe
quelle heure du jour ou de la nuit
la situation est donc très critiqué
notamment dans les alpes du nord et dans
le haut jura où les avalanches coupent
les routes isolées village et comme
chaque année surprennent les imprudents
et tu en suisse plusieurs chalets ont
été emportés dans le valais les lignes
électriques sont coupées les routes
bloquées pas victime heureusement dans
le valais encore un déraillement près de
copines stein plus spectaculaire que
meurtrier sept blessés seulement
c'est miraculeux la locomotive a été
happé par l'avalanche à la sortie du
tunnel des travaux de déblaiement du
rond-point dureront plusieurs jours
dans le canton d'uri cette coulée est
arrivé en plein village
c'est à peu près ce qui s'est passé à
tour en haute savoie au dessus de
chamonix mais là il y a eu quatre tués
et deux disparus près de saint jean de
belleville deux employés des ponts et
chaussées une jeune fille ont été
emportés les recherches n'avaient pas
encore abouti ce soir à la tombée de la
nuit
enfin sur l'autre versant du massif du
mont blanc dans le val d'aoste
l'avalanche a fait six morts trois
touristes belges et trois résidents
italiens
les six victimes ont été ensevelies dans
leur voiture on les a retrouvés mais
trop tard ce soir il neige encore tous
les moyens et personnels de secours sont
en alerte les consignes de sécurité sont
diffusés dans toutes les stations et
tous les villages mais il n'y a pas que
les avalanches il ya aussi aujourd'hui
les inondations les pluies et la fonte
des neiges ont provoqué une brusque crue
de la garonne notamment à toulouse où
certains quartiers ont dû être en partie
évacué aujourd'hui le gers qui avait
connu des inondations catastrophiques
l'été dernier est à nouveau menacée par
la montée des eaux
tout comme la haute garonne et l'ariège
et puis paris non plus n'est pas épargné
le niveau de la seine est à trois mètres
60 la cote d' alerte se situe à 3 mètres
10 les voies sur berges sont fermés ce
soir à la circulation les otages du
tchad
mon fils n'est pas un espion je demande
aux membres du frolinat d'avoir une
attitude humaine envers lui le père de
christian maes pris en otage le 18
janvier dernier en compagnie d'un jeune
technicien suisse par le front de
libération du tchad
s'interroge aujourd'hui comme tout le
monde sur les raisons qui ont fait de
son fils à l'otage
nous allons entendre tout de suite les
premiers réflexions du père de christian
maes est ce que vous pourriez nous
expliquer pourquoi votre fils se
trouvait actuellement en afrique et
notamment au tchad il faisait un très
long périple en afrique
c'est un voyage qu'il avait préparé
depuis longtemps et il avait l'intention
d'aller au cameroun était parti d'alger
et tamanrasset agadez niamey et il
allait il ne savait pas très bien à
l'époque que s'il devait passer à c'est
à dire de la dernière lettre qui nous
envoyait ne sait pas très bien si vous
passez par le nigeria ou par le tchad
pour se rendre au cameroun
et finalement il a décidé
malheureusement deux de passer par le
tchad et c'est la roue cet événement est
arrivé vous aviez des nouvelles de lui
alors effectivement on avait
régulièrement des nouvelles de lui nous
envoyer des lettres votre sympathique je
crois qu'ils qu'elle nous disait qu'il
était en pleine forme et que fait il
avait un certain bonheur pour un certain
équilibre je crois que je vais trouver
pourquoi avait-il choisi plus
particulièrement l'afrique pour voyager
au il n'avait pas forcément choisi
l'afrique pour voyager ils étaient
partis étaient partis en auto stop il
devait rencontrer ce camarade andré dont
l'espagne maroc à l'algérie
il descendait l'afrique n'était pas
voulu la danse le voyage qui était voulu
ce n'est pas le lieu
forcément le frolinat l'accusent
aujourd'hui d'espionnage oui alors là
c'est complètement sa frappe cette
histoire c'est tout c'est impensable
complètement impensable
on ne sait pas comment vont réagir les
gouvernements français et suisses devant
les demandes de rançons poser pour la
libération de christian maes et
d'andré-pierre kummer ling son ami
suisse
pour l'instant les du gouvernement
français et suisses ont pris contact
avec la croix rouge internationale
mais ce qui ressort de cette affaire
c'est que la rébellion tchadienne loin
de s'étioler s'est installé dans le pays
non plus seulement dans le nord dans le
tibesti mais beaucoup plus au sud
beaucoup plus près de la capitale du
tchad djamena les guérilleros dépenaillé
d'hissène habré ont laissé la place
aujourd'hui à des unités de dix
militaires habillés et armés d'une façon
moderne
quelque part dans le nord du tchad près
de large au un groupe de maquisards du
frolinat tu est accroché par l'aviation
gouvernementale
visé par les bombes une palmeraie où les
rebelles viennent se ravitailler et se
rafraîchir
ces images tournées il y à peine
quelques semaines témoignent des
difficultés rencontrées par l'armée
tchadienne pour contrôler un territoire
où les rebelles se font chaque jour de
plus en plus nombreux de plus en plus
présent créée en juin 66 quelques années
après l'indépendance du tchad le
frolinat tu as connu des fortunes
diverses jusqu'à ce que le colonel
kadhafi lui accorde son appui
aujourd'hui le frolinat tu et équipés
d'armes soviétique la plupart août neuf
fusils bazooka armes automatiques
ils viennent directement de libye a
bataillé dur exemple cette mitrailleuses
anti-aériennes de fabrication soviétique
le maniement très simple mais très
efficace et qui a probablement servi à
abattre dimanche dernier le dc3 tchadien
où se trouvaient trois sous-officiers
français face à l'armée tchadienne qui
compte environ dix mille hommes équipe
essentiellement d'armes françaises et
russes les rebelles aligne environ 6000
hommes divisés en quatre armées la
première de 1000 hommes contrôlent
aujourd'hui le sud du pays
à l'est l'armée volcan moins nombreuses
mais très bien entraînés puis l'armée
mourdi bien coordonnée avec l'ami
l'armée la mieux organisée celle de
goukouni qui compte 2000 hommes
goukouni oueddei il porte un chef au
centre le voici il a 32 ans fils du chef
spirituel des toubous son prestige est
considérable chez les rebelles
actuellement il tente de réunifier les
différentes tendances qui existe au sein
du frolinat car il faut bien comprendre
que cette rébellion qui se réclament du
frolinat tu est partagée en différentes
armées mais qui opère chacun de leur
côté sans commandement unique comme par
exemple c'est tout bon du tibesti qui
contrôle le nord du pays
et puis voici les toubous de la région
burcu où a été abattu le dc3 une armée
qui gonfle au rythme de 150 volontaires
par jour
enfin voici cette arme est surnommé
volcan composé d'arabes tchadien très
bien armée très bien entraînés qui
harcèlent sans arrêt les troupes
gouvernementales y votent à l'aise au
sein de la population
le frolinat tu très dominateur comme un
politique n'a pas encore réussi à
s'unifier totalement mais chaque jour
les volontaires affluent comme en
témoigne cette troisième armée dont on
découvre l'existence
parce qu'elle vient de prendre en otage
un suisse et un français le front est en
baisse à paris sur les principales
places financières en trois jours la
mêlée française a perdu 3% les valeurs
françaises elles ont perdu 13 ou 14%
depuis le 1er janvier
à l'opposé les valeurs refuge
traditionnelle c'est-à-dire l'emprunt
pinay ou l'or grimpe au plafond 806
francs aujourd'hui pour le pin est 299
francs pour le napoléon et 29 1290
francs pour le lingot mauvaise séance à
la bourse de paris où les valeurs
françaises à l'ouverture perdent un peu
plus de 2%
c'est surtout au sous-sol de la bourse
qu'il y avait foule aujourd'hui pour
assister à la cotation du franc
malgré quelques interventions de la
banque de france discrète mais certaines
et le relèvement du taux d'intérêt sur
le marché monétaire
le franc a encore perdu du terrain par
rapport à l'ensemble des devises
étrangères
le dollar gagne 6 centimes à 489 le
coach marc 4 centimes à 2 francs 32 et
le franc suisse
un peu plus encore à deux francs 48
heures
la cause de ce mouvement est à chercher
uniquement du côté des incertitudes
politiques
à cinq semaines des élections
législatives étant turn offrant prennent
leurs précautions
ils vendent les français qu'ils
détiennent pour acheter des devises
étrangères
il se couvre
c'est un mouvement général les vendeurs
sont aussi bien des particuliers que les
entreprises ou des banques aussi bien
des sociétés françaises que des sociétés
étrangères
mais pour l'instant le repli s'effectue
en bon ordre ici à la bourse
l'ambiance aujourd'hui était certes
mauvaise mais sans aucun mouvement de
panique
face à cette situation monétaire de
réflexion aujourd'hui de monsieur
raymond barre à lyon le pays est
vulnérable parce que à l'heure actuelle
la monnaie n'est pas seulement détenus
par les résidents de ce pays a les
détenus également par des non résidents
a déclaré aujourd'hui donc monsieur
raymond bas nous devrons être très
attentifs à assurer la valeur et la
stabilité de notre monnaie
le gouvernement poursuit le premier
ministre est responsable de la politique
économique de la france et donc de la
monnaie française
il veillera à éviter une détérioration
sur les marchés des changes
il prendra les mesures nécessaires pour
limiter la baisse de notre monnaie il en
a les moyens a conclu monsieur raymond
d'un dernier congrès d'une grande
organisation syndicale le congrès de la
fédération de l'éducation nationale qui
s'est tenue aujourd'hui cette semaine à
nantes et qui s'est terminée donc
aujourd'hui elle s'est tenue cette
réunion de la femme sous un double signe
incertitudes vis-à-vis de l'avenir
politique de la france et volonté
syndicale de faire aboutir les
revendications des travailleurs de
l'enseignement monsieur andré henry a
cependant été réélu à une très large
majorité secrétaire général de la
fédération de l'éducation nationale
le rapport de force n'est pas modifiée
au sein de la fen la majorité proche des
socialistes s'est légèrement renforcé la
minorité animé par les communistes s'est
un peu tassé sous l'habillage syndicale
on a beaucoup parlé politique un ans
mais le ton est resté mesuré à cause de
l'échéance électorale de mars
comme si on ne voulait pas jeter de
l'huile sur le feu
quel que soit le résultat des élections
notre attitude syndicale est constante
nous demanderons gouvernements quels
qu'ils soient des négociations sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur les conditions
d'emploi
nous demanderons à reprendre cette
réforme qui hélas est en train de
détruire notre école de façon à faire
enfin un bon système éducatif pour les
enfants
excusez moi de le dire après le 19 mars
il y aurait 20 mars qui est beaucoup
plus important et le 15 septembre que
monsieur habib soit encore milices et
c'est pas ça l'essentiel pour nous nous
aurons des élèves dans nos classes vous
avez peut-être noter que dans ce progrès
comme dans les précédents nous avons mis
l'accent
nous avons insisté sur la situation des
personnels je crois que l'opinion
publique ne s'est pas assez qu'il ya
encore dans notre profession des
salaires inférieurs à demi fond les
quarante quatre syndicats de la fon se
retrouvent pour souhaiter une autre
politique économique et sociale qui
selon eux passent par la victoire de la
gauche
andré henry a mis en garde une nouvelle
fois le pc les travailleurs ne
comprendraient pas qu'il n'y ait pas
désistement le 19 mars
enfin le secrétaire général de la cen
insisté fortement sur la laïcité la
nationalisation laïque est une solution
généreuse nous proposons l'unité de
l'école pour assurer le vrai pluralisme
de penser dans les corps pour garantir
le droit à la rencontre des jeunes
enfants qui ne saurait a jamais porté
comme des stigmates les différences
idéologiques de leurs parents que l'on
reconnaisse donc le droit de l'enfant et
pas seulement le droit des parents
le courrier sera peut être rare durant
les prochains jours dans la région
parisienne selon les syndicats tous les
centres du tri postal sont en effet en
grève depuis ce matin 10 heures origine
de ce conflit l'intervention de la
police ce matin tôt dans la matinée vers
6 heures dans le centre de tri de
créteil et l'expulsion des employés qui
occupait ce centre de tri depuis samedi
dernier depuis huit jours les postiers
de créteil demander la réintégration
d'un jeune vacataires licenciés en
octobre dernier selon un communiqué
publié
le ministère des ptt seul l'évacuation
du centre de tri pouvait permettre
d'assurer la liberté du travail aux
agents non grévistes en politique
l'événement de cette journée c'était la
rencontre françois mitterrand vibrante
l'ancien chancelier ouest allemand est
arrivé peu avant 10 heures ce matin à
paris et à 10h30 les conversations
commencé dans l'une des salles de
l'assemblée nationale devant les
journalistes après s'être rencontre
monsieur willy brandt et monsieur
mitterrand souligné que l'avenir de
l'europe continuait de dépendre du degré
de coopération entre la france et
l'allemagne et bien sûr la question de
la participation de ministres
communistes dans des gouvernements
d'europe occidentale a été posée par
l'un de nos confrères
elle n'a pas surpris ni monsieur
mitterrand ni mathieu quand je
m'exprimerai là dessus je me suis
exprimé billy branch ga parole qu'est ce
qui va vous répondre vous le savez
avance considère que ce n'est pas son
affaire
et avec acciona
alors que tous les axes de notre analyse
of gab le bug de berger fra grèce
kemball césar est de france aux hommes
willy brandt me permettra de dire à sa
place il aurait pu également répondre je
ne sais pas encore si à mes amis
socialistes français trouveront auprès
des communistes français le même
concours que naguère
le général de gaulle monsieur mitterrand
qui était à nancy cet après midi devait
d'ailleurs affirmé qu'il n'y avait
jamais eu de négociations avec le parti
communiste à propos justement de la
répartition des ministères pour monsieur
mitterrand une telle négociation ne
pourrait avoir lieu avant de connaître
bien sûr les résultats définitifs du
second tour des élections législatives
de mars prochain en marge peut être de
cette campagne électorale une bombe a
explosé cette nuit devant la porte de
l'appartement de monsieur georges mais
monsieur menin et député du 16e
arrondissement
les dégâts sont très peu important et
puis en marche aussi de cette campagne
électorale un rendez vous demain
monsieur yves guéna sera l'invité à
12h30 de notre émission samedi et demie
demain donc samedi à 12h30
monsieur yves guéna au moment où
monsieur willy brandt arrivé en france
en successeur à la chancellerie
ouest-allemande monsieur helmut schmidt
était obligé de replâtrer son
gouvernement quatre de ses ministres ont
décidé de démissionner le plus connu
d'entre eux c'est monsieur georg les
beurs le ministre de la défense qui sera
remplacé à ce poste par l'actuel
ministre des finances monsieur hans
apple après un scandale d'espionnage la
carrière politique de monsieur georg les
bords et maintenant achevé les problèmes
de monsieur helmut schmidt ne sont pas
terminées bourreau de
c'est la démission du ministre de la
défense qui a déclenché la crise
gouvernementale de bonnes souriant
malgré ses ennuis gay or kléber ancien
maçon social démocrate devenu chef des
armées fédérales ne cessé d'accumuler
revers et erreurs depuis plus d'un an
les scandales succédé aux affaires
d'espionnage ainsi qu aux écoutes
illégales de ses collaborateurs par le
contre-espionnage de bonnes meagher
kléber mal informés s'efforçaient de
minimiser ces incidents
d'autres ministres comme el mout rod
instruction publique et marie fly qui
s'occupait du développement du tiers
monde sont également les victimes de ce
remaniement mené à chaud ces retraits
sanctionne des échecs politiques notable
pour remplacer ses ministres peu
convaincant helmut schmidt a dû choisir
leur successeur parmi la jeune relève de
son parti des hommes du type jeunes d'où
l'expression allemande existe à peine
hagrid 35 ou 40 ans ce faisant le
chancelier brûle un peu ses dernières
cartouches dans la solitude de verre et
d'acier de sa chancellerie
helmut schmidt s'est en effet que les
talents se font rares dans son propre
parti
son prestige personnel reste intacte
mais l'effritement de son équipe
gouvernementale est devenu pour lui un
casse tête permanent
est ce une coïncidence
l'arrivée à alger du colonel kadhafi
semble avoir donné une impulsion
nouvelle aux travaux de ce que l'on
appelle le front de la fermeté que les
états arabes hostiles aux négociations
entre égyptiens et israéliens ont décidé
cet après midi de créer un commandement
suprême politico militaire il s'agit là
de la première mesure prise réellement
par les pays du front de la fermeté un
front qui a été créée en décembre
dernier sous le nom de front du refus
cela semble-t-il ne trouble pas
exagérément le président anouar
el-sadate après avoir rencontré le roi
hassan ii du maroc le chef de l'état
égyptien aborde la partie la plus
importante de son voyage il est attendu
aux états unis où il rencontrera le
président carter le français est
désormais la seule langue officielle au
québec la loi avait été votée en août
dernier le représentant de la reine
d'angleterre avait jusqu'à présent
refusé de parapher cette loi c'est chose
faite aujourd'hui
et puis en dépit de l'opinion de bon
nombre de membres du congrès américain
le gouvernant de monsieur jimmy carter a
décidé de ne prendre aucune mesure
économique
l'encontre de l'ouganda l'ouganda du
maréchal idi amin dada ce sont les états
unis qui actuellement achète la presque
totalité de la production ou landaise de
café l'enlèvement du baron empain l'
affaire est maintenant entre les mains
du juge d'instruction chavagnac cela sur
le plan de l'action de la police ne
change d'ailleurs pas grand chose le
dispositif policier sera maintenu et
adaptée aux nécessités de l'enquêté ce
qui a précisé cet après midi le porte
parole du ministre de l'intérieur quant
aux barons pas eh bien cela fait
maintenant douze jours qu'il a disparu
et puis un télégramme vient de me
l'apprendre jean philippe milliau qui
est âgé de 25 ans et qui était le
chauffeur des tueurs de l'ardèche vous
vous souvenez de cette affaire en août
dernier jeu pierre conti l'assassinât de
trois personnes
en lozère et bien jean philippe milliau
s'est constitué prisonnier jeudi après
midi
il est actuellement incarcéré à la
prison de la santé il s'est présenté
volontairement devant les policiers
accompagné de son avocat les résultats
du commerce extérieur le prouvent les
français on fait attention cette année
ils n'ont pas dépensé plus de pétrole
que prévu mais cela ne change rien au
problème la france comme tous les pays
d'occident doit trouver d'autres sources
d'énergie
la semaine dernière dans un article
publié par notre confrère le monde
monsieur giscard d'estaing évoqué
l'énergie solaire et c'est bien dans
cette direction qu'il faut chercher en
effet les américains l'ont bien compris
edwards lors s'en est rendu compte il ya
quelques semaines dans le désert du
nouveau mexique il aura suffi de
quelques secondes pour transpercer ces
deux plaques d'acier par la simple
action de quelques miroirs solaires
et pour quelques 21 millions de dollars
5 milliards de centimes le gouvernement
américain tente depuis deux ans la plus
gigantesque expérience au monde pour
percer les secrets de l'énergie
développée par les rayons du soleil
dans le désert du nouveau mexique sur
une superficie de 4 hectares 300 module
composés chacun de 25 miroir devrait
permettre de fournir 5 mégawatts
d'énergie thermique correspondant
approximativement à 1 mégawatt ennemis
d'énergie électrique
au total cela pourrait pourvoir à la
consommation quotidienne en électricité
de 15 cents maisons individuelles
mais pour les spécialistes américains il
ne s'agit là encore que d'une expérience
encouragée par le gouvernement qui vient
d'allouer un crédit de 100 millions de
dollars 500 millions de francs
au programme de développement sur
l'énergie solaire la technique pour
capter l'énergie solaire est sans doute
aujourd'hui pratiquement au point son
application à la vie quotidienne les
beaucoup moins l'énergie solaire captée
par les miroirs convergent vers une tour
de 100 mètres de haut qui supportera
divers types de chaudières produisant de
la vapeur à haute pression et chacun des
300 miroir pivote contrôlée
électroniquement en fonction de la
position du soleil
une expérience qui devrait permettre de
tester les miroirs leurs qualités leurs
défauts tester également les chaudières
améliorer leur rendement pour obtenir la
plus grande puissance en fin de circuit
les premières tentatives ont commencé il
ya une dizaine d'années les spécialistes
américaine il trouve aujourd'hui que peu
d'espoir d'utilisation qui pense que
nous en sommes au tout début on vient
juste de quoi leur style ce n'est plus
classé expérience colossale jusqu'aux
est en train de voir derrière moi je
pense pas avoir encore beaucoup de
chemin à faire pour en arriver au stade
commercial première application hommes
du type genou l'expression allemande
existe à peine âgée de 35 ou 40 ans ce
faisant le chancelier brûle un peu ses
dernières cartouches dans la solitude de
verre et d'acier de sa chancellerie
helmut schmidt s'est en effet que les
talents se font rares dans son propre
parti
son prestige personnel reste intacte
mais l'effritement de son équipe
gouvernementale est devenu pour lui un
casse tête permanent
est ce une coïncidence
l'arrivée à alger du colonel kadhafi
semble avoir donné une impulsion
nouvelle aux travaux de ce que l'on
appelle le front de la fermeté que les
états arabes hostiles aux négociations
entre égyptiens et israéliens ont décidé
cet après midi de créer un commandement
suprême politico militaire il s'agit là
de la première mesure prise réellement
par les pays du front de la fermeté
affront qui a été créée en décembre
dernier sous le nom de front du refus
cela sur le tilt ne trouble pas
exagérément le président anouar
el-sadate après avoir rencontré le roi
hassan ii du maroc le chef de l'état
égyptien aborde la partie la plus
importante de son voyage il est attendu
aux états unis où il rencontrera le
président carter le français désormais
la seule langue officielle au québec la
loi avait été votée en août dernier le
représentant de la reine d'angleterre
avait jusqu'à présent refusé de parapher
cette loi c'est chose faite aujourd'hui
et puis en dépit de l'opinion de bon
nombre de membres du congrès américain
le gouvernant de monsieur jimmy carter a
décidé de ne prendre aucune mesure
économiques à l'encontre le look
da l'ouganda du maréchal idi amin dada
ce sont les états unis qui est
actuellement achète la presque totalité
de la production ougandaise de café
l'enlèvement du baron empain l' affaire
est maintenant entre les mains du juge
d'instruction chavagnac cela sur le plan
de l'action de la police ne change
d'ailleurs pas grand chose le dispositif
policier sera maintenu et adaptée aux
nécessités de l'enquêté ce qui a précisé
cet après midi le porte parole du
ministre de l'intérieur quant aux barons
pas eh bien cela fait maintenant douze
jours qui la disent pas et puis un
télégramme vient de me l'apprendre
jean philippe milliau qui est âgé de 25
ans et qui était le chauffeur des tueurs
de l'ardèche vous vous souvenez de cette
affaire en août dernier du pierre conti
l'assassinât de trois personnes
en lozère et bien jean philippe milliau
s'est constitué prisonnier jeudi après
midi
il est actuellement incarcéré à la
prison de la santé il s'est présenté
volontairement devant les policiers
accompagné de son avocat les résultats
du commerce extérieur le prouvent les
français on fait attention cette année
ils n'ont pas dépensé plus de pétrole
que prévu mais cela ne change rien au
problème la france comme tous les pays
d'occident doit trouver d'autres sources
d'énergie
la semaine dernière dans un article
publié par notre confrère le monde
monsieur giscard d'estaing évoqué
l'énergie solaire et c'est bien dans
cette direction qu'il faut chercher en
effet les américains l'ont bien compris
edwards lors s'en est rendu compte il ya
quelques semaines dans le désert du
nouveau mexique il aura suffi de
quelques secondes pour transpercer ces
deux plaques d'acier par la simple
action de quelques miroirs solaires
et pour quelques 21 millions de dollars
5 milliards de centimes le gouvernement
américain tente depuis deux ans la plus
gigantesque expérience au monde pour
percer les secrets de l'énergie
développée par les rayons du soleil
dans le désert du nouveau mexique sur
une superficie de 4 hectares 300 module
composés chacun de 25 miroir devrait
permettre de fournir 5 mégawatts
d'énergie thermique correspondant
approximativement à 1 mégawatt ennemis
d'énergie électrique
au total cela pourrait pourvoir à la
consommation quotidienne en électricité
de 15 cents maisons individuelles
mais pour les spécialistes américains il
ne s'agit là encore que d'une expérience
encouragée par le gouvernement qui vient
d'allouer un crédit de 100 millions de
dollars 500 millions de francs au
programme de développement sur l'énergie
solaire
la technique pour capter l'énergie
solaire est sans doute aujourd'hui
pratiquement au point son application à
la vie quotidienne les beaucoup moins
l'énergie solaire captée par les miroirs
convergent vers une tour de 100 mètres
de haut qui supportera divers types de
chaudières produisant de la vapeur à
haute pression et chacun des 300 miroir
pivote contrôlée électroniquement en
fonction de la position du soleil
une expérience qui devrait permettre de
tester les miroirs leurs qualités et
leurs défauts tester également les
chaudières améliorer leur rendement pour
obtenir la plus grande puissance en fin
de circuit
les premières tentatives ont commencé il
ya une dizaine d'années les spécialistes
américaine il trouve aujourd'hui que peu
d'espoir d'utilisation je pense que nous
en sommes au tout début on vient juste
de lancer ce la plupart des expériences
locales au stade jusqu'aux est en train
de voir derrière moi je pense qu à
présent pour beaucoup de chemin à faire
pour en arriver reste acte commercial
première application pratique sur cette
base d'albuquerque la concentration
d'énergie solaire porte la température
de l'huile qui circulent dans ces
conduits à 300 degrés et c'est ensuite
par un processus plus traditionnels
convertisseur de chaleur et générateurs
que l'énergie solaire se transforme en
électricité
on utilise cette électricité pour
alimenter les bâtiments qui abritent les
spécialistes américains en imaginant
qu'il soit possible d'élargir cette
expérience un jour dans la perspective
des dix ou vingt prochaines années
pensez vous qu'un jour l'énergie solaire
pourra se substituer à l'énergie
nucléaire
je ne pense pas qu'elle puisse la
remplacer je pense que j'ai donc deux
énergies complémentaires l'énergie
nucléaire fournira toute la puissance
nécessaire à l'industrie lourde tandis
que l'énergie solaire fournira de
petites quantités d'énergie par exemple
pour les maisons individuelles les
maisons individuelles c'est sans doute
l'exemple le plus connu et le plus haut
point de l'application pratique de
l'énergie solaire le gouvernement
américain aux prises lui aussi avec un
programme de restrictions l'énergie va
tenter d'en généraliser l'utilisation un
système peu coûteux qui fournit à chacun
aux chaudes et électricité
enfin toujours dans ce désert du nouveau
mexique
une autre tentative remplacer le gaz
comme source d'énergie par l'énergie
solaire
112 miroir qui alimente un générateur
complot du sous sol et permet d'irriguer
en permanence 40 hectares de terrain
cette fois l'installation est coûteuse
mais la production de gaz est limitée et
n'est pas évident que l'accroissement
des prix des matières premières n'en
fasse pas d'ici quelques années une
opération rentable en sport eric tabarly
a triomphé et pour l'honneur dans la 3e
étape de la course autour du monde c'est
officiel maintenant les organisateurs
entre nous ce sont des anglais les
organisateurs refusent de le classer
motif invoqué pen duick 6 le bateau de
tabarly est muni d'une quille en urines
une en uranium appauvri
cela n'est plus ou alors pas encore
conforme aux règlements internationaux
la fédération française de voile peut
cependant encore faire appel de cette
décision
en football tirage au sort des 16e de
finale de la coupe de france quatre
matches surtout à retenir nice paris
saint germain 3 marseille sochaux
saint-etienne et strasbourg bastia ou
bien strasbourg calme et puis en ce qui
la france est passée ce matin à côté du
podium dans le slalom spécial le dame
juste à côté
perrine pellen termine 4ème et fabienne
serra cinquième de ce slalom
la victoire est revenue à l'inattendu
soltner une autrichienne devant
l'allemande femme et la mère
c'est une jeune autrichienne de 19 ans
les assauts teneur compagne de chambre
et de anne marie paule qu'est devenu cet
après-midi championne du monde de slalom
spécial
et de quelle façon dans la première
manche elle est seule la seule a
effectué son parcours en moins de 42
secondes
quarante et une secondes 82 centièmes
exactement
dans la seconde elle n'est devancée que
par monika casey ray rue de ses
compatriotes et de cinq centièmes de
seconde seulement
cette année pourtant elle s'était
surtout consacré à la coupe d'europe
quel est d'ailleurs en passe de
remporter une très grande championne
vient certainement de neige quant aux
françaises elles ont fait de leur mieux
perrine pelen troisième à l'issue de la
première manche et devancé finalement
par monica caster elle ne montera pas
sur le podium comme fabienne sera
d'ailleurs qui est 5e
dans l'état actuel du ski français on ne
pouvait guère attendre au mieux de leur
part
enfin il nous reste encore le slalom
géant dames en commençant ce journal je
vous parlais avalanche et inondations
cela risque de durer la météo nous
annonce un temps couvert avec de la
neige et de la pluie sur le massif
central et le bassin parisien
ce type de temps devant gagner ensuite
l'ensemble du pays et après ce passage
très nuageux le ciel demeurera variable
avec quelques belles éclaircies sur
l'ouest
voilà cette édition est maintenant
terminée à 22h45 environ faire des
clones tiendra au courant des derniers
développements de l'actualité de cette
journée
bonne soirée et bonne fin de semaine à
tous